[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i
can't i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
uh
there's something out there i'm coming
with you
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from
what it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can kill it
[Applause]
[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people and someone dies i
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
he didn't die okay the wedding
[Music]
johannesburg
it's time for some change you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
[Music]
we need to find a person who took that
case
[Music]
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia job the twins yeah and i'll
switch it to their twins get off the
train
[Music]
you stab me
coming for you what
i missed my stop something else going on
here hi
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm i'm working on it
get off at the next stop i'm so easy
when you say it one little prick from
this you know what happens yes your
blood congeals
yes
you're going to want to hear the whole
story which way unfortunately
with his army of assassins there's this
soulless psychotic leader with the
largest criminal organization on the
planet shoved right inside
i don't see the white death letting any
of us off this train
we need to come up with a plan
[Music]
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i i gotta get off the string
[Music]
sorry buddy
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
what if i told you
that today
you'll leave here
different
i'm talking
to you
bro what'd you see someone above the
clouds that's big i'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
[Music]
right here
you
are gonna witness
an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
this could be an opportunity i'm talking
rich and famous for life there's plenty
of videos for flying [ __ ] online nobody
gonna get what we gonna get what are we
gonna get the money shot what's up
undeniable proof of aliens on camera the
oprah shot
you guys gonna tell me what's going on
hell no
something out here are you the only
person in the world that can get it on
film
that cloud they move the niche it's
aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
i'll be rooting for you
i think we pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
they gonna come back
you ready
we got some work to do
nope i'll get him out
and i'll get the shot let's go baby
let's go
i need you to tell me what did you see
in that cloud
[Music]
was not what you think
they took me
they took them all
i gotta get out this house i'm trying to
save you my brother is out there
i don't think they thank you
if you don't look at it
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
five stars angel five stars
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
now
i kneel before no one
[Music]
heroes don't kill people
well i do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
you know my fresh coat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once upon a time in a magical castle
the king's daughter
was knocked away in a tower
you made a promise to me
that your daughter will be my wife
i'm not a piece of property to be traded
but these guys
[Music]
with the wrong princess
i like a girly lace
[Music]
i have to save my family
let's get you ready
it's not exactly lady-like behavior
[Applause]
[Music]
i underestimated you i'm used to that
who are you
[Applause]
i'm the princess
[Music]
[Music]
starlight star bright
first star i see tonight
i wish i may
i wish i might
have the wish
i wish tonight
[Music]
wow
[Music]
good evening
welcome to hawthorne it'll be our
pleasure to feed you tonight will be
magical
over the next few hours you will ingest
fat
salt
protein
and at times entire ecosystems we're
eating the ocean we're eating the ocean
are you crying
it's just i find it all very moving so
it's okay but i'm not as into this as
you are
oh my god
you shouldn't be here tonight
you my dear guests
are not the common man isn't that right
is he going to keep doing that what
happens inside this room is meaningless
compared to what happens outside
we're about a frightened nanosecond
any questions
this is bergamot i'm getting chef
yes it is
[Music]
[Music]
wow
i did not see that coming
[Music]
hey this is the training montage isn't
it
don't forget to land on your
feet
focusing on me
the smell of victory
i have something to tell you i am your
father no i'm not
pause the fury the legend of egg
[Music]
prepare yourself for a journey beyond
what is possible walt disney animation
studios proudly presents strange world a
new motion picture event brace yourself
travel past space and time to a place of
infinite mystery unlike anything you've
ever seen
where in the world are we
[Music]
what in uh
[Music]
i'm not an explorer i'm a farmer
[Music]
we need to get out of here
if you want to back out this is the time
to do it
really
no
messing with you come on let's make
history
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
now what
[Music]
i've waited all year for this all right
oh
my family spends every summer in cousins
beach with my mom's best friend and her
two sons conrad
and jeremiah
they've always seen me as a little kid
but this summer see you guys later it's
different damn you look hot stop
flirting with my sister
dude focus
i wrangled belly an invitation to be a
debutant
shut up stephen the whole dev scene
it's for sheep conrad could you be a
little more supportive now which one of
you is gonna be belly's escort to the
ball
wow guys stop fighting over me
susannah told me she knew i was destined
for one of her boys i always hoped it
would be conrad
we almost kissed concentrate but then
there's jeremiah you're no best friend
third time i wanted anymore what am i
gonna do
[Music]
we're playing with a lot of hearts belly
boys might come and go but our best
friend is once in a lifetime
i really wish you were here
ellie you don't really affect your
people
how do you know when it's the right
person i just feel right
[Music]
does this look like the sky or the ocean
to me they look the same
and what if they don't fit anywhere
that's how your mother felt
she felt like she didn't belong
[Music]
said she was dead she's dead the day she
left his house all right
he'll want you
don't you dare
let go
[Applause]
what are we gonna say when we go back
you're into dirt bikes
what's your favorite ride are you a
mcmahon link's make mac no i'm not it's
mickey mouse yeah we don't need your
help
that's all that regalia for dancing a
good dancer can make a big cat
you any good
[Music]
[Music]
whatever you want to do
you don't know how long
[Applause]
engaged
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening
[Music]
nobody moves
this
i need to know everybody's alive and
well
you just have to trust me
come on
incoming
we made a deal
you broke it
wally what are you doing up there i
tried to text you but my phone died my
phone died
that's it i didn't mean to scare you i
swear i'm down here right now not you
you stay up there
there's one option but the operation is
risky so when you're having the surgery
i don't know how do i tell my daughter
i'm kind of it for her
so how are you
let's go somewhere we've never taken a
real road trip together no way it's the
rest of summer we're going i will be
miserable the entire time i will teach
you to drive on the way if you have a
good attitude for real i'll let you get
behind the wheel if you promise to never
do that again ever i will never ever do
it again get out
all right
good we're gonna see so much good stuff
driving when you look back on this trip
i want you to remember you and me
spending time together not you waiting
for your boyfriend to come
i need you to drive i didn't know your
headaches were this fun you never tell
me anything
clear go now did you close your eyes
no always keep your eyes open one second
okay
is this what a midlife crisis is no
yes
i bet on you i want you for my whole
life
you have a fire inside you wally life is
gonna pull some moves to try and put it
out trust yourself
[Music]
t-minus 10
four
three
two
one
zero ignition
[Music]
they are [ __ ]
i think the floor is not working
look at that number up there on the
billboard there's a two and then
some kind of circle no dumbass not that
number that one
69
this show sucks like just these fat
people standing there i am
who are you fart knockers i'm using yes
beavis and butthead do the universe a
new movie streaming june 23rd
exclusively on paramount plus
this changes everything
everything was perfect
just like i imagined
please
i'm afraid we're gonna spoil this dress
[Music]
welcome to your home away from home
this dwelling was built by architect
frederick banner in 1955.
if i had to be stuck in a house it could
be worse than this
[Music]
do you think he's watching us
oh
yeah
i remember reading that banner was
obsessed with the occult
his wife disappeared under mysterious
circumstances his young son went into
foster care eldritch what's the address
house 1960 marion lane i'm in his actual
house
hello i must have gotten the days mixed
up we have a book till tomorrow i'm
eldridge the owner
[Music]
i think i saw someone in this house
i'm worried just let me know you're okay
do you live
[Music]
here think i found some human remains
my father committed multiple murders
[Music]
the spirit is able to escape death it
must have been a lord of watching
eldridge it's really into his father
help me put an end to him
good morning everybody today we're gonna
paint a portrait pick a partner that's
so good can i see yours
that is great
never shown my feelings in public how do
you know when you have a crash i have a
theory first insta story is the person
you're thirstiest for mine is called
call zuwabi
i have a huge crush what's her name
kelso
i don't know what this is
but i like it it's not pull your hair
out scream it out the window for the
whole world to hear the kind of deal
[Music]
wow no i'm stupid
i hate when people say i'm brave you're
transitioning so young i can't tell you
how brave you are it's not that brave if
you're just being who you are
these are
for you
[Music]
carl and likes you yeah well i like like
you if you don't like me just tell me i
don't want to be your friend i didn't
say that we could live our own life or
spend the rest of our life wondering
what it is
[Music]
so you've officially set the school on
fire maybe we should
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are my exceptional daughter and what
is unique about you does not make you
hard to love
for the first time in my life i'm
actually excited about what's to come i
truly feel anything's possible
oh my god
go away that is so awkward
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]